- All right,
hi everyone, hopefully
you're all ready for this.
So, very quickly, I am Jon Griffiths,
I'm the field CTO at Dynatrace,
and we're the ones sort of
sponsoring this talk today.
I'm here today with Ishan.
- Hi everyone. I'm Ishan Singh.
I'm a senior data scientist
on Amazon Bedrock AgentCore team.
- I'm Matthew Eisengruber,
I work for CDL. I'm the
head of Architecture.
- Yeah, and I work with
Matt, I'm Chris Buckley.
I'm head of operations.
- So today we're gonna
have a really exciting time
for you today.
So we're basically gonna be looking
at CDL's journey with AI,
how they've gone from early
stages in development,
all the way to actually
releasing their AI in production
and how, of course, Dynatrace
and AWS has supported them in doing this.
Now, as you'd expect, gonna start
with a little bit on Dynatrace first.
So just to check,
are any of you here Dynatrace customers?
A handful, so that's
a good start at least.
So to give you a very quick introduction,
what Dynatrace is
Dynatrace primarily focuses
around observability and security,
but the essence of it
and where it really comes from
is really pushing the
boundaries on AI and automation.
Now, this isn't just a matter
of helping you understand
and observe your AI,
but also AI within our own platform
to enable you to understand
the root cause of problems
to automatically detect those problems.
And, of course, start to self remediate
those problems as well.
As you can see with this slide,
it covers everything
from your application,
your infrastructure,
your customer experience,
your developer experience,
the business observability as well,
and even delving into, of course,
the AI and LLM observability as well.
Now, the way that we're
effectively doing this is,
of course, the more we move towards AI,
the more we have been moving
with microservices and so on,
the more data there is, the more volume,
the more velocity of data.
And the issue with data
is that with the scale
that it's at nowadays, you
just don't have the time
or resources to actually
look at it individually
and actually diagnose
and investigate,
say each individual log
line or whatever it may be.
So what we're doing is
we're trying to take all
of that data in context.
Now that's both from a top
topological point-of-view.
So actually understanding
those logs, those metrics,
those traces, those events
against those topology entities,
but also understanding it within
the context of your domain.
You know, your application
domain, your services domain,
your infrastructure
domain, whatever it may be,
and understanding how
that actually applies.
Now the importance of that
comes in when you actually start
to apply automation and AI on top of that
because any automation
or AI based on bad quality data
will lead to bad quality answers
and decisions being made.
So, of course, we're trying to emphasize
how ensuring that good quality
data is really key to that,
both from Dynatrace's own AI,
but also if you start to
utilize your AI agents
through our MCP servers and so on,
to actually access
and utilize the data that
we're storing as well
to really drive forward your
business, to enable your teams
to do whatever it is that
they they need to do.
Now when we look at AI as a whole,
it's not just say the
application layer, you know,
again, you need to
understand the full context,
the full stack of the AI agents
or GenAI observability piece.
So, of course you've got
the different layers in
that you've got the application layer,
but you've also got say
the orchestration layer.
And, of course, there you can start
to understand things like the caching
that's taking place and so on.
You then got the semantic layer
with your vector databases
and so on where again
you start to understand
the different performances
and inputs and outputs
and semantic analysis
that's effectively taking place on that.
And continuing down your actual model,
an agent layer
and again, understanding
exactly what is being utilized
and how the token usage
and, of course,
the importance of that
onto things like cost.
And then finally,
the actual infrastructure
computational layer
where you're looking
at things like the GPU,
the resource utilization
and so on as well.
Because any one of those layers,
if not tuned appropriately
for the other layers, makes
things go bad very quickly.
Whether that's your cost
spinning outta control,
whether that's the performance
becoming really poor,
or whether it's actually
just providing you
with decisions and answers
that you're not expecting
or that it shouldn't be providing you.
Now from a dietary's perspective,
in the AI observability area,
where we focus on are
these four use cases,
the first one being cost and performance
and looking at how we can control that,
looking at token utilization,
looking at prompt caching
and performance around that.
So again, starting to
understand how you can improve
that cost of your AI engines.
And then moving on to
things like explainability
and debugging with traces,
the focus here is tracers,
because you have that
end-to-end understanding.
You have that ability to have
that explainability knowing exactly
which agents it went through,
knowing exactly which models
it's actually utilized,
not just the ones that were requested,
but actually the ones that
ended up being responded to.
And again, that leads on quite
nicely to the compliance side
of things as well,
because obviously with compliance,
you not only need to understand
what the actual input and output was,
but you actually need to understand
why it made the decision it made,
you know, which, at
which layer, which tier,
which agent did that start
to divert down the wrong
path when you start
to get into compliance issues
and start to get into queries around that.
So again, having that full explainability
of what happened when it happened
and why is very important for that.
And then finally, of
course, is the guardrails
and the safeguards.
'cause one of the biggest issues
with AI most of the time is trust.
So, of course, you need to ensure
that your guardrails are
being utilized appropriately.
You need to ensure that
the safeguards are there
and you need to ensure that
what you're actually providing
is what people are expecting.
You know, you are actually
providing the answers
that they should be providing
without any other issues coming in.
Because once you lose trust,
your AI suddenly loses
its entire business case
associated with it.
And finally, of course, we've
been partnering with AWS for,
for quite a long time
now, well over 10 years.
And as you'd expect, we've
gone through all of the sort
of compliance standards and
certifications around AWS.
So again, of course, things
like the GenAI competency
as well as the many others
that are listed here as well.
But again, ensuring that we are mapping
and managing against the standards against
how AWS is setting those to ensure
that not only are we doing
things in the right way,
but we're also doing things effectively
and efficiently with AWS's own services,
both from a perspective of
utilizing it within Dynatrace,
but also how we're providing
visibility of AWS's services
for our customers as well.
So now I think, you know,
I've done my little bit
of sales pitch.
We can now sort of hand over
to I guess the main reason why we're here,
which is obviously CDL and their story.
So Chris, why don't we start
with a introduction onto CDL
and take it from there.
- Yeah, yep, okay, before we get going,
if I could get everybody's
attention, could I get everybody
to stand up audience participation time?
Not joking, just stand up
for me. Stand up for me.
I know, it's like third day in.
You guys are (indistinct).
All right, stand up, okay.
Who here knows who AWS is?
If you know who AWS is,
stay standing, okay.
Who here knows who CDL is?
If you don't know who
we are, please sit down.
More than I thought, also, thank you.
Because before we came on
stage, I made a bet here
with my colleague 'cause we are in Vegas
and I said I would get all of you
to give him a stand when he started.
So thank you, I just won that bet
- And you get the round
of applause every time.
And I just brought me
down a race socks a bit.
No, lucky socks, man.
that's what made it bet.
- Excellent.
- Yeah, so I think I'll
stand. So who are CDL?
We are a B2B software company based
outta Stockport, Manchester, England.
We deal with B2B.
So we deal with directly
with the companies.
As a team, we are 600 strong
and we consider ourselves, you know,
at the top of our game in
the UK insurance industry.
The big green button, you said it, yeah.
Yeah, that'll be great.
- So one of my favorite quotes
that I heard from one of our
suppliers is CDL are the veins
of the UK insurance market.
What does that mean? It means
we are experts in our field.
In the UK, if you're gonna do
a or transact a private car,
household, motorcycle
or GV quote on online,
at some point in that journey,
you will touch one of our systems.
Typically we say we deal around
60% of all the transactions.
So just to try and bring that to life,
I'm Joe Blocks, I've purchased
a new vehicle in the UK.
By law, I have to ensure that vehicle.
What do I do?
Typically, I'll go onto
one of the aggregators.
So in the UK that might be go compare,
it might be money supermarkets.
I will go on there
and I will enter my details.
All personal to me, my vehicle,
my address, and I'll click get quote.
When you click get quote,
that'll be your first interaction
with one of our CDL systems.
Might not a big interaction,
but it will be an interaction.
If the premium displayed
or the price is good,
I'll click go to buy.
Again, chances are 60% of the
time you'll be linked straight
through to one of our customers.
If you go ahead to buy that
quote with that customer,
that policy would then be
administered on our system.
So far we've done the quote and buy,
now we run to the policy administration.
But also when it comes to the
regulation side of things,
our systems then tell the UK government
that vehicle's insured.
So in the UK we have ANPR cameras.
If we don't, if we don't tell the systems
that you're insured based
on your registration number
and who you are, you're gonna
get pulled over by the police.
So, you know, it's quite a, you know,
important sequence of events.
So from CDL we do the
purchase, the quotes.
We do the policy administration.
We do the payments.
We do the renewal,
and we let people know
you've actually got the vehicle insured.
And one of the things it's important
to mention it's high volume
retail we deal with, okay.
We're talking that the
amount of quotations
going through our system is,
you know, silly at times.
And that's where Dynatrace comes in
from an observability perspective.
They give us that real time
insights of what's going on.
You know, as a customer I
will not wait for a premium
to be showed, why?
The market's that competitive
that I'll just go to the next one
and it might be 10p cheaper.
Yeah, so that's why it's so
important that we understand
through Dynatrace
what our systems are
doing all of the time.
Now I did mention it's an ecosystem.
So there's, you know, a
raft of numbers up there
to show the scale that
we operate at in the UK.
As I said, veins of the
UK insurance market.
We are the middle of that bubble, okay.
The amount of integration
into other systems is vast.
Once again, some of it's like touch,
some of it is our complete
product of our complete service.
But likes at some point
in a insurance quote journey in the UK,
you will touch one of our systems.
One of the scary figures in
2024 in just our bubble alone,
Dynatrace observed 1
trillion transactions.
We don't know this year's numbers,
but I dunno the one to
count them to be fair.
But we expect it to, you
know, increase significantly.
Where Dynatrace also comes
in is this is, you know,
highly interconnected.
If someone on the outside has an issue,
it impacts all the way through.
Previously without Dynatrace
we always got the finger
pointed at us, or it must be CDL.
We use it, must be CDL.
But what's not considered
is all the other entities
in the chain of getting a
quote, paying for the policy,
administering the policy.
So a Dynatrace comes in,
it instantly tells us
where that problem is.
Ideally it's not CDL
and we can use that
information proactively
to tell our customers the
issue is here you need to go
and speak to that vendor,
that particular supplier.
So wrong button, there we go.
So as the title said, you
know, POC to production,
where did it all start?
I think, and hopefully
he's watching, you know,
we are blessed with a
very knowledgeable CEO
and when it comes to AI,
he's very much pushing
the organization to do it.
They always say top-down approach
and he lives and believes that, you know.
He's always challenging us to,
you know, know what's
going on in the market.
So I feel, you know, we
are blessed with our CEO
that is constantly challenging us.
We're not having to convince
him we need to start looking
to AI with our products and services.
He wanted us to build
something new and exciting.
Give something with a VR headset,
gimme voice, gimme vision,
give multimodal, give me
something and I want it yesterday.
You know, he is always pushing
us to do more and do better.
So I think, you know,
from that point, you know,
we had the early concept
design things that we wanted
to kind of progress with,
but the business ask was,
we've got the products.
We've got the services.
We've got the ecosystem and
we've got the knowledge.
Let's go and build something.
- I guess now that you know who CDL is
and I guess what the high
level business ask was,
I guess the question is,
Matt, with your technical
insights, where did you start?
- Make 'em stand again.
Make him stand again.
- Right, yeah, so as Chris said,
CEO is chomping at the bit, right.
He's got the GPT Max subscription,
he knows the capabilities of things.
Most of the rest of the
board actually uses Gemini
in their personal lives and things.
So got a decent
understanding at board level.
So you kind of can't pull
the wool over their eyes.
Like I'm not gonna blind
them by science, right.
So we were a little bit on the back foot
and he actually went on stage
and we did a company all hands
and he said, right, we're going AI inside.
So for those Intel fans,
remember the Intel inside logo,
that's kind of what he was playing on
to get it in our heads like it's gotta be
inside everything we do.
So he did that bit and
then it was like, okay.
and then he got asked the
question, somebody said,
"Well you know, hey big boss,
do you have all the, do
you have all the answers?"
And he went, "No, I absolutely
do not have all the answers."
And then he pointed to me
and the team in the back
and he went, "But those guys
will. They'll figure it out."
So it was like no pressure, right.
So anyways, we were a
little bit on the back foot,
but then once we got thinking
about it, as Chris said,
it was, well actually
there's a bit of a journey
that we took to get to the
ecosystem that we were in
that put us in a pretty decent position.
So first off technology.
Well we used to have two
data centers in the UK
for those of you that know the UK,
they were just outside
Manchester in our Stockport area.
And we made a call
because what we kept
doing is landing bigger
and bigger customers and
we weren't able to scale.
So we went, right,
we're gonna go cloud
first is how we started.
And we went right, we're
gonna go cloud first.
so any new customers, we're
gonna put 'em on AWS, good.
And we went, we got a few customers,
a few big customers on AWS.
We went, you know what,
this is actually really good
and the old stuff isn't really that good.
So then we went cloud only,
moved all our customers over in two years.
So now we got all our
customer base on AWS,
that's important because now,
now we've got the agility
and the ability to adopt
new tech when it comes out
as we're leading into AI, right.
Next thing we did is it's not
just enough to move to cloud,
you also have to have
things that are accessible.
As John said, you need
to have context for AI
in order for it to be useful.
So luckily we had
adopted a product mindset
about being API first.
So almost all our
services, which also helped
with the interconnectivity, right,
We needed to make it
easier for our customers.
But again, it plays
heavily into the AI space
in that we adopted this
AI first mentality,
which means that data can
now be surfaced to AI easier.
So two key things there,
cloud migration and API.
Next thing we did, which most,
I know it's a tech conference,
but you're all people, right
So we focused on our people
and went, what do we need to do in order
to get our people there?
So as part of the cloud migration,
we actually upskilled all our engineers.
So Chris said at the beginning
we were 600 strong company,
250 of those people are engineers.
We made it a mandate
that every engineer had
to get the cloud
practitioner certification.
We did this not because we're mean people.
We did this
because we wanted everybody to
be able to talk the language
so that when we walked into a room
and said a word like S3, EC2, Bedrock,
no one had to ask what is that?
So we upskilled the language
that everybody's talking
on the same plane.
Next the other thing that we did
around this is we tried
to change the culture.
So I don't like to use the
Silicon Valley term fail fast,
but what we did is we made it
so that exploration was fun and safe.
Safe as in like you're
not gonna get a backlash
because if the idea
doesn't work, it's okay.
So how we did this is we did things like
incubators and hackathons.
So we created events for our engineers
with their new found skills now
and we gave them exposure
to the technology
'cause that's the most
important thing that we found
even with our board
is that the more exposure you give to AI,
the less fear there is around it.
The more the understanding is around it,
the easier it is to push forward.
So that also kind of wasn't enough
because of the way that we work
and the highly regulated industry
that we're in we're like PCI
DSS and all the rest of it.
We also needed to do what's right
and we wanted to do it the right way.
So we also started to look at our process.
So once we got our people
skilled up, it's like okay,
but we probably got some processes
that aren't gonna help us.
So one of the first things we did is we
formed an AI steering group.
Now the steering group was
composed of a few executives.
So again, had that top level down support,
it was compliance and legal
'cause again, the hurdles
that we figured we were
probably gonna come up against
are the same hurdles we're
coming up against today,
which is compliance and legal
and cybersecurity challenges, right.
You guys all know what it's like, right.
You build the software
and then you almost make it out the gate
and then it's like pump
the brakes we're right.
We didn't wanna make that mistake.
So we included them in that conversation,
in that steering group.
And also we had subject matter
experts like architecture,
there's actually the fellow
in the room over there.
He's also in that group.
And that was so
that we could bring that
deeper AI understanding
into that AI steering group.
So we've got decision makers.
We've got experts that
understand our interaction
with our customer, which
is really important.
So the steering group,
it allowed us to clarify
our why across the piece.
It also kept the customer in the room
because we were talking
about things like contracts.
Like okay, we're gonna be
using their data differently.
Do we need to redo contracts?
AI is gonna be more transactional.
Do we need to think more of a SaaS model?
Is it gonna be outcome based?
How are we gonna do this?
We need to steer those
decisions at that level up there
so that like the CEO said, "We
don't have all the answers.
So we needed to form that group
to begin to give the answers
to the people so they can
build the right thing."
So centralizing the big
decisions made it easier for us
to coordinate and then roll
those out across the piece.
We also adjusted current
processes to streamline adoption
of the AI tooling and services themselves.
So again, we're regulated and things.
So we needed to make sure
that if we were gonna introduce something,
we weren't data leakage, right.
Like somebody wasn't gonna upload
some of our developer code into ChatGPT
and that's stored in the
states, which is a big
no-no when you're in the EU.
So it's like, okay, we needed
to watch those kind of things.
We also needed to do that
because the pace of change that AI brings,
and this is something
that you kind of feel it
when you go to cloud, like
that kind of speeds up
and it's like AI's like that on steroids
as far as you need to be
able to make decisions
very quickly as an organization
because week to week it's changing.
Now cloud,
it used to be you could go to
a conference like this, right.
You go to re:Invent and then
afterward everybody goes home
and before Christmas you
write up your plan for,
here's all the stuff from re:Invent
that I'm gonna introduce in the next year
until next re:Invent.
AI is like that every week.
So we adjusted our
process to streamline this
so that as evolving tech shows up,
we can evaluate that
and bring that through.
So to give you an example,
when a new model drops,
so I believe it was the Claude 4.5 model,
we had that approved via
this group within 48 hours.
So we could start using it.
Previously, this would've taken
probably about three months.
So you gotta look at your process as well.
We also used that time to
kind of reevaluate who we were
as a company around ethics.
So it's a good time to kind
of sense check, you know,
who you are to your customers.
Again, keeping 'em in the room.
So one of the things we did there was
it helped us encapsulate
some of those requirements
around like how,
'cause it's one thing to do
ai, it's another thing to,
like I said, do it right.
So with us, our tagline is
making powerful partnerships.
So how you do that, as
John was alluding to,
is you have to maintain trust
and you have to be transparent
about what you're doing.
And us as a B2B, we ultimately
have to be transparent
because we're the platform
that our customers operate on
and they need to know
how their lifeblood of
their business is running.
So I mentioned we're a
highly regulated industry.
There's two reasons I
wanted to mention this.
One, we got PCI, we got GDPR.
Some of those might not be considerations
for some of you in the room as US people.
But one of the other
things was we were looking
for like an AI standard.
And at this point in the journey,
there's a thing called ISO 42001
that like was in its infancy.
It wasn't really understood yet.
So we didn't actually have
anywhere to go with this,
but we were watching
that because we figured,
you know what, that's probably
gonna give us some trust.
It's gonna help us build
trust with our customers.
So what we did do is we leaned
on the well architected.
So our product we built will be FTR ready,
if you're familiar with that.
So foundational technical review.
So we made sure they got verified by AWS
that we're technically correct.
And then we wanted to
go for the ISO standard,
which I'm happy to say
we've just received
over the last two weeks.
So we've actually got
an ISO 42001 AI system.
So that should help us
both in the pre-sales
and around the trust and transparency.
Another thing that was
happening in this time,
you gotta go back, this
is like back in January,
is security, right.
So in traditional web world
you've got like entities
like OWASP, right.
So it used to be dead easy with cybersec
'cause you go right OWASP
top 10 for web, right.
We're gonna throw advanced
shield on top of that,
put a WF in front of
it, use the manage rules
that AWS give us cybersecurity signs off.
We're good to go.
So we're like, right,
what's OWASP got for us?
And they didn't have anything at the time.
And then literally I
said that to the board
and then a week later,
the OWASP top 10 LLM exploits came out.
But there's no managed rule set for that.
So we went, okay, right,
this system has gotta have a guardrail.
We're gonna have to figure out guardrails,
but at least we know
what the requirements are
gonna be for these guardrails.
'cause we'll lean on OWASP.
- So let's bring all that together.
We've got a CEO who's on board.
We've got the ecosystem
to make a difference.
And what I mean by make a
difference is we're going
to be able to use AI at a large scale
with trillion transactions.
You know, you saw some of the numbers
before about quotations.
Our system has 7 million policies.
How can we use AI
to help our customers transact
and manage those policies cheaper?
Yeah, so it's all about
efficiencies and productivity.
We need to address compliance at pace.
You know, we are in a
highly regulated industry
as Matthew said,
but we brought everyone
along on the journey.
But AI goes at pace,
so how do we keep up,
how do we ensure we're
using the latest tech?
I said before with the
center of the ecosystem.
So we're in prime position to
make a real life difference
to how that industry works.
And also we've got the products.
You know,
when the CEO first said
build me something in AI,
we all went to it and said, right,
"What new product are we gonna build?
What new shiny thing are we
gonna bring to the market?"
And we kind of, you know, went to,
"Oh, we need to make all
these fundamental changes."
and the CEO's credit, "No,
no, we've got the products.
we've got the services.
We AI needs to utilize those
to make the difference."
So it meant we had to be a lot more
surgical in our thinking.
It wasn't wholesale took
all that in the business,
start again.
It was, we've invested
35 years in developing
all this technology,
these relationships at how people used it.
So we had to take a much
more surgical approach
in how we were going
to embed AI in those
particular services and yeah.
- Yeah, so I think it's
obviously good to see there that
it wasn't just a matter of
going in all guns blazing,
building anything and everything.
It was a thought process
that started this.
It was understanding exactly
what should be happening,
why it should be happening
and changing not just what
they were trying to do,
but also changing the internal processes
to actually make what they
wanted to do work for the future.
Not just to get it out,
but also to continue that
momentum going forwards.
But I guess back to
Matt, the big question is
that the technology, right.
Yeah. How did you start piercing it?
What did you start using and and so on.
- Yeah, 'cause this is a juicy bit, right.
This is why you guys are here.
So we just said the CEO was
using this AI inside terminology
and then the CTO, which is our boss
came in and he had this
concept of, he said,
"We need this engine room layer."
So we, like Chris said, we
don't wanna throw it all away.
We've got all these APIs
that got all this rich
information and accessible.
We need to have a layer though.
We need to have an engine room
that our customers can connect to.
Similar to the front door we were trying
to create with the API.
So we took that away
and architecture had a bit of a brain dump
and we went, right, this
stuff is changing so fast.
You gotta remember LLMs, were dropping.
This is what, like, you
guys know how it is, right.
Anthropic releases one and
they go, we're the best.
And then (indistinct)
releases one, we're the best.
And then ChatGPT, we're the best.
And they've all got different
evaluation ways of metrics
and it's like, how are you supposed to.
so I looked at this
as if I was an investor
and an investor, you've got
two different strategies.
You've got active investing,
which is where you go and you pick a horse
or you got passive investing,
which is where you buy an index
and you just invest in the market.
So I said, right,
based on how much these
guys are leapfrogging,
I don't think picking a
horse is the right example.
And everybody's like, yeah,
that, that makes sense actually.
So I said what we, what
we'll do is we'll come up
with a mechanism that
allows us to evaluate these.
So we need something that allows us
to chop and change the models,
but also evaluate them so
that we're not regressing
when we do change a model.
So we're not going backwards
if we make a change.
The other side we needed to worry about
was the insurance industry
isn't exactly the fastest
moving place, right.
We're do some cool things around volume
and we use technologies
in clever ways sometimes,
but it's not the most
forward thinking, right.
So we knew that in order for
our customers to get on board
with this, we were gonna
need to introduce this
as a thin slice of value.
So I'm gonna sound a little
bit like a product person now.
So we needed to get this
thin slice of value,
but that thin slice had to
be across that tech stack
that we were trying to create,
and then that needed to be quite modular.
So we could go right, once we've got that,
we're gonna wash and rinse and repeat that
and keep introducing these thin slices
so that our customers can
go on this journey as well.
'cause otherwise we're
gonna tear their face off
as we're going and nobody's
gonna wanna jump on with us.
So that was the ideas.
And then we're like, all right,
pretty sure somebody's
figured this out before.
So the first thing we did
is we reached out to AWS.
So as you guys go down this
and once you've defined
your why, like we were,
and you've got some of your, how,
now is when you start
leaning on the platforms
that you've chosen and your partners.
So we leaned heavily on AWS.
So we got in our AWS solution architect.
We gave 'em that.
We said, right, we need something
that gives us model selection.
We also need something that
does evaluations quite quickly
so that we can chop and change.
Like that's a major requirement
on the technical side,
you know, we also need it to be secure.
We need to have guard rail, you know,
gave him the whole dump.
And he went,
"Actually Matt, we got a good one for you,
it's called Bedrock."
I was like, excellent,
Bedrock sounds great
. What is it? Yabba Dabba
Doo? All right, let's go.
So that was cool.
So we're like right Bedrock,
start researching that.
Then we reached out to John
here and we said, "Hey John,
you helped us when we moved to cloud.
We mandated that that Dynatrace
had to be on everything
when we moved to cloud.
You switched on the lights for us.
What's your answer for AI?"
And John goes, "Well, funny
Matt, I got something for you."
And he pulled up this dashboard,
I was like, "Oh it's pretty good, John.
What am I looking at?"
And he said, "Well it's
traditional Dynatrace metrics
in the sense of you've got
your performance metrics
and things.
But what it also did,
'cause we knew we needed to worry about
security performance cost, right.
Typical IT problems, that's all in there.
But what it also opened
our eyes up to was things
that we hadn't considered yet at the time,
which was behavioral metrics of AI.
So things like relevance and grounding
and how many times you've denied a topic.
So you've triggered a guardrail
because somebody's tried
to exploit something.
And that was like, okay, yeah actually
that's really useful.
And then our head of products saw this
and he went, "I absolutely need that
because this is the first time
that I've tied together
performance metrics
with AI based metrics, with
token usage, with cost.
So now I've got the whole gamut.
I've got everything, which is great.
"So we said awesome, we're
gonna push forward with this."
So Dynatrace became a main component
of this from the POC stage,
observability was required.
So we didn't wait.
Day one, it was like we're doing this.
So this is all the you
guys have been waiting for.
This is we got out our big box of crayons,
started drawing pictures,
that's what architecture does.
So on the right-hand side here
is the ecosystem Chris was talking about.
We've obviously only got one
service on the right hand side there,
but that was our API interfaces.
What we then did is we layered Bedrock
on top of that using a
multi-agent approach,
that's a supervisor with
then subagents below that,
that are domain-specific.
There's reasons why we did this.
Most of the reason was as you
guys will have found out now,
so it's like hindsight was 2020 on this,
as we were going to
expose those interfaces,
remember this is before MCP was a thing,
so MCP wasn't out yet.
we needed to keep our domain
of what that agent knew.
We needed to keep that as
as specialized as possible
so that we could use the smallest model
possible for the highest accuracy.
So that's always the balance
you're trying to play, right.
Small model, but then on your front
where your supervisor is,
you want that one to have
like ultimate reasoning.
So it can utilize the
downstream agents very cleverly.
So it's gotta interpret
what the customer's trying
to say on the right-hand or on
the left-hand side coming in.
It's gotta interpret that reason that,
and then farm out the work to say,
Ooh, you wanted to do a quote.
Well I'm gonna send you
to the, the quote agent
or you wanna make a change to your policy.
Maybe you've gotten married
and your name's changed.
I'm gonna send you to the MTA,
which is a midterm adjustment
agent, which is just,
I'm just changing a certain
detail about my policy.
What we all, what that also did though is
Bedrock gave us really firm guardrails.
So the guardrails in Bedrock are amazing.
They're really flexible.
So you can do it on the input,
which is great,
so that when somebody
tries to act like a grandma
and or trick it into giving
you admin privileges, it won't.
It also does things
like it can prevent data
like oversharing.
So somebody might ask for something
which is seemingly okay on the way in.
So you wouldn't wanna block it,
but the model itself might overshare,
maybe some PII, we don't want that.
So you can block it on the outbound.
So that's all really great.
The other thing we did, as I
said, the observability bit,
we leaned on OpenTelemetry.
I don't know if you guys are
familiar with OpenTelemetry,
but if you take a step
back into Dynatrace world
for a second here, Dynatrace
came out with Pure Path,
which was essentially the
precursor to OpenTelemetry
for those that dunno.
So OpenTelemetry is the open
source version, essentially.
Peer Path was their proprietary thing
that pretty much was a claim to fame.
So we already had Peer Path
on the right-hand side.
So we needed to find a way to extend
that Peer Path back out to our customer
'cause that's where all the value is.
So Dynatrace has got an
SDK that you can drop in
to Bedrock, which is what we did.
So we dropped in this SDK
and all of a sudden we lit up Bedrock
and we can see all the inputs and outputs
and all the times a guardrails triggered
and we can tie that back
to the backend system calls as well.
So now we've got tracing from customer
to backend, which is brilliant.
- One thing you didn't
mention the model story
about the costing.
So the reason I always get
Matt to mention this is
that it's bringing business insights
based on that dashboard.
So is it worth mentioning or not.
I always throw you under the bus, but--
- Which one's that one?
- The costing one, the
model that VINCI version.
- Oh yeah, so one of the things
that we got off the
observability quite early on,
are you talking about the the
one where we had exhaustion?
Yeah, so we were using a model
and we were almost ready to
launch it into production.
So this was like gonna
be the premier launch
and then we hit a thing
where we were getting errors
and had we had not had
observability in with Dynatrace,
we wouldn't have saw what that error was.
The error was actually token exhaustion
and the solution was really
simple, update the model
'cause we were using an end
of life model, that was it.
But had we not had any of that,
we would've spent weeks trying
to figure it out, right.
But we were able to do that
and then it didn't delay our release.
- Cool, thank you, so for my own sanity,
I had to put a simplified
version of the previous slide
because I'm probably the least technical
person here at Dynatrace.
But very briefly what we
can see there is I mentioned
vision and voice at the start.
So we've got, you know,
the multimodal digital,
how customers want to make
those changes to the policy.
We've got Amazon Connect at the top
or AWS Connect at the top for that,
for that voice side as well.
So it's the same engine powering
all these different inputs
on the customers and it's
given them the choice.
They have the choice of
what they want to do.
And then going back to,
you know, at the start,
we wanted to throw all
the products in the bin
and build this brand new AI thing.
What we've got in the middle
is this AI engine room
that Matthew spoke about, Matthew,
what Matt spoke about
before, Agent intelligence.
And that's what we are
engaging our customer with now.
So it's not mass wholesale change,
it's a compliant product.
We've got legal buy-in.
We've got compliance buy-in
and we're not scaring our customers.
We're going after the low risk change.
And in the UK market, low
risk change is our change
that don't impact the premium.
So change in your telephone
number would be a good example.
Updating your marketing preferences,
don't send me any more junk mail,
those kind of things.
So yeah, I just wanted
to include this kind
of slide as a precursor
to what the complex scary
AWS diagram looked like.
- [Jon] I guess now that we've done
that exciting, nice and
deep explanation there,
I guess the real question is
with so much change going on, you know,
and as you said before MCP service existed
and obviously having
to architect all this,
how was that learning curve?
How did you adapt
and ensure that all of
your teams were able
to follow that learning curve with you?
- Funny you should ask, yeah,
I've got a slide on that one.
So to me, Matt touched on it
before, right at the very start
and it's about culture.
It was very much about
bringing people along
on that journey,
making sure everyone was
using the same terminology
in a technical sense,
but also with the use of the AI dashboard,
everyone using the same
business language as well.
So to me the the biggest
learning curve was language
and understanding across the business.
However, what we also came
across were, you know,
items in the news.
So being non-technical,
I hear the, the the the phrase DeepSeek
and I'm in a panic
contacting Matthew going,
"We need to start again.
We need to throw everything out."
You know, DeepSeek come
along, it's cheaper, faster,
what all that kind of good stuff.
And this is where the
groundwork we've put in
at the start starts to pay dividends.
- Yeah, so going back to that diagram,
if you remember one of
the original requirements
was we needed a mechanism
for evaluating models.
So this is where it started
to pay the dividends, right.
I got my first dividend kick
out of this passive investment.
So Chris came to me, rightly so, right.
'cause there's like trillions
wiped off the market overnight.
He goes holy smokes,
DeepSeek, what are we gonna do about it?
What's the answer?
He wasn't the only one asking.
CEO was asking, board was
asking, what are we doing?
Is this something we need to jump on?
Is this something we not need to jump on?
So what we did is we used
Bedrock's evaluation capability
via LLM as a judge and other things
and matched that with
Dynatrace's observability
to look at the metrics
and go, right, do we need to chase this
or is this just market hype for us?
Right, I'm not saying it's
market hype for everybody,
but in our particular case,
what we did then is we
actually wrote a blog on it
and posted it.
So if you look for CDL
and you look up DeepSeek,
you might see the blog
that we wrote on it.
We actually gave the eval
stats and our testing methods
and how we did that.
So that was a really quick
way for us to not lose focus
because with all this change
coming, one of the things
that you're gonna constantly
have to remind yourself
is why are you doing AI
and should you jump on the next thing?
Like when's the next time to jump on it?
The other thing that
Chris was talking about,
about terminology is
there's a lot of three
letter acronyms in IT.
There's a lot more three
letter acronyms in AI
and there's protocols getting
released all the time.
So A2A, AP2, MCP, right.
I would say those things
and I wanted the board to understand.
So a lot of that terminology
I would bring to the board
and say MCP is this,
this is what it means.
And then I would encourage
them to go and use that
and almost give 'em like
a homework assignment.
It's like one of the
things I did is I said,
"Right has anybody tried a
different mode besides chatbots?"
And like nobody raised their hand.
I said, "Right, how many
of you you use Gemini?"
I went, "Oh yeah, everybody, okay cool.
Use Gemini Live, try it
tonight, try it with the kids."
And that's how we started to
introduce it into the boards
to get them because then the fear reduces
and they start to see the potential.
- Yeah, so protocols, you know,
this journey started
probably back in January
and everything was new.
MCP was new, A2A was being mentioned.
I'm frantic trying to keep up.
But one of my kind of favorite times
of the month was when it
came to the board meeting,
our CEOs, our CEO you know,
highly educated in what's
going on in the world of AI
and he's always trying to out
AI Matt, you know, saying,
"I've learned this, I've read that.
What are you bringing to the table, Matt?"
So, you know,
the kind of the, the AI
world is always changing,
but what I'm starting to, you know,
as a non-tech person is
starting to enjoy is the world
of MCP, the world of Dynatrace MCP,
but also being able to
connect that to Kiro as well.
So you know, the tech is now starting
to put it in someone's hands
that doesn't fully understand tech.
You know, the Dynatrace MCP
with Kiro, I can see us rolling
that out to a almost service desk level
where the service desk now are able
to service our customers using, you know,
this kind of AI text.
So it's not only B2B,
well no, it's only B2C,
it's also B2B now as well, Matthew.
- Yeah, so around what
Chris was talking about,
again, this goes back to
the, that AI steering group.
So because of that AI steering group,
we were able to get Kiro
approved again within a few days
and we rolled that out
to all 250 engineers.
What we then did is we held
a hackathon a couple of weeks
after we enabled that,
got Dynatrace to give us
early access to their MCP,
which is hosted, which is great, right.
Hosted MCPs are way better
'cause you don't gotta manage 'em.
And then we had AWS come in
and help us with a Kiro training session
and then we combined all that
and our last hackathon that
we had a couple of weeks ago,
we had 23 teams submit
and of those 23 teams, 21
of those teams used Kiro
and some form of MCP, some
with Dynatrace, some without.
So we're seeing a massive adoption
and it's like making changes,
but again, it's helping people
get over that hurdle of,
you know, that learning curve
and understanding the protocols
and what MCP means for them and their day.
Because I gave a a thing
and I said think about the things
that make you wanna get
out of bed in the morning.
Don't use AI for those.
Think about the things that
makes you wanna stay in bed.
Those are the things that
you wanna automate with AI
and to explain some more
of what AWS is offering is
around this 'cause I talked
a little bit about Bedrock,
a little bit about Kiro and
I'm gonna hand over to Ishan
to talk about some of
the further developments.
- Thank you Matt,
so we looked at building AI agents
is a part culture journey.
We also looked at how different
offerings like observability
through Dynatrace helped serial
CDL go in production work
and build these agents.
We also looked at how evaluations along
with observability was the
key to get to production.
So we at AWS believe that AWS
is the best place to build,
deploy, and operationalize AI agents
and if you are looking for the recipe
to building the agents,
you're in the right place.
So let me give you like a four point note
on what are some of the successful ways
you can build the AI agents.
So starting with you need
to have a use case defined,
which has a clear success criteria.
Success criteria is often a
mix of not just the quality
but also latency cost and don't
miss out on good experience
because that's what you're
building with these AI agents.
So as you're building these agents,
you are often looking
at different frameworks.
You are looking at different models
so that you know no one model
can solve for all the problems.
So you need a choice of models.
You're also looking at how
can you securely, safely
and reliably deploy these
AI agents in production.
And lastly, you're also looking for
how do you make these
AI agents discoverable
to your other organizations,
other teams maybe externally to customers?
To do all of this, let's
look at the portfolio
that AWS has across different AI services.
So on the top we have
the out of box agent.
Agent tech features like Kiro.
Kiro is our code built tool.
You can build spec-based
agents using that.
Then if you come little down from
that in the center you have Amazon Bedrock
and AgentCore which provides
you with like inference,
sorry, inferences for the models.
It gives you like ability to build agents,
deploy agents in production
and then as you need more control in terms
of the infrastructure that
powers all of these agents
and like your use your workflows,
you may want to like look
into the infrastructure side
of the things like SageMaker
provides you with the choice
of like how you customize
these different instances.
You can also look into the
AI compute side of the things
with Trainium and Inferentia
So these are a lot of offerings
and today we are talking about AI agents,
building them in a reliable way.
So I want to focus
only on the Amazon Bedrock
AgentCore side of the things.
So these are nine different
services offered under
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
So I'll start with the runtime
and I'll try to describe
each of those on a high level
because we have roughly 15 minutes left.
So agent Go runtime is
where you can deploy any agentic framework
that uses any agent model,
sorry, any LLM model
and you can do that on scale.
So super easy to go production
by deploying your agents
on AgentCore runtime.
Agents need memory
so that they can
personalize the responses.
So AgentCore memory comes in handy there.
It can seamlessly work with your agent
and all of these are production ready.
All the services that we
see here are composable.
So you don't have
to like use specific
services in a specific order.
You can just pick any,
use those wherever you are in the journey
of building these agents.
Then we have identity, which
is such an important aspect
of controlling what access
does this agent have,
what tools it can invoke
and so on and so forth.
Then we have gateway which exposes like,
which actually acts like a central,
let's say central place
to host all your tools
such that your agent can
talk to them seamlessly.
Then we have code,
interpreter, and browser.
These are the built-in tools
you can just associate directly
with your agent in again,
using any framework, any model.
So you could just associate those
and use these out of the box.
They're ready for the production agents.
Then you have built in observability
and yesterday we also launched
policy and evaluations.
So policy helps you.
So we first looked at
identity, which controls
what access the agent has,
and then policy comes in
and helps interrupt wrong
actions that an agent can take
because as you know,
agents are powered by
large language models,
which are non-deterministic.
So agent code policy helps in
to intercept any unexpected behavior.
A typical example of that would be like,
let's say your agent can
refund on your behalf
and you have a policy that,
hey, I don't want any refunds
to be issued that are
over a thousand dollars.
So if you want to implement
this AgentCore policy is
something that would come very handy.
Then evaluations is another offering
that we had launched yesterday.
It provides you like
with built-in evaluators
that you could use,
but you can also extend
these two custom evaluators.
They are LLM as judge-based.
So let's look at how
AgentCore different offerings
within AgentCore work together.
So as we see in this diagram,
we have AgentCore runtime
in the center of it.
So you can deploy again
any agent framework,
let's say for an example, strand agent,
it could be a LangGraph,
could be LangChain,
LlamaIndex, anything really.
So you can deploy any agentic framework
that is using any agent
model, sorry, any LLM model.
And it can seamlessly interact with memory
to get the personalization,
sorry, personalized records
of the context that you
want to feed into the agent.
The runtime AgentCore
runtime also seamlessly
interacts with gateway.
Again, there is an
authentication layer here.
So every time your agent
that's hosted on runtime
also has to get like a
access from the identity
in order to go through the gateway
so that it can seamlessly fetch tools.
Search through tools
and search of tool
in the gateway is such
an important feature
because you may have hundreds of tools,
maybe thousands of tools and
you don't want to feed all
of them into the agent's context.
So that it really gives you
that relevance and efficiency
that you are after.
And then if you look at the
tools, there is browser tool
and core interpreter, you can
seamlessly associate those
into your agent.
And observability and evaluation
sort of sits through across all of these
and you get observability not
about just the agent tracing,
but also like,
hey, how many requests
were raised to my gateway?
Was it authenticated or not?
Did my agent invoke the memory?
What was fetched from it?
What was written to it?
And all those good things.
So I spoke a lot about the capabilities.
How you build,
like these are like compostable services,
so you could use these to build AI agents,
but as I mentioned earlier,
you're really after
creating a good experience
and technical capabilities
are not so, sorry,
technical capabilities are
not equal to good experience.
Good experience is the only
one feature that matters
as you're creating these AI agents.
With that, I'll hand over to John.
- Yeah, so I think, obviously,
we've had most of the CDL story now,
but I think that the key part here,
especially with what Ishan's been saying
about the sheer breadth
of the AWS platform and
what can be provided
and the reality of
how much new capabilities
have come out in, you know,
the recent even weeks, even
this week specifically,
but you know, the recent months and so on.
How did you as CDL know when it was right,
when it was time to move into production,
when it was the appropriate time
and you weren't just adding on
new capabilities continuously
and continuously, when was it
right to move into production
and, of course, how was the
actual rollout into production?
- All right, well, I'd say,
we knew we were ready for production
when AWS was verified it with the FTR.
We achieved the ISO standard
or we were on the path to achieving it
because I think we actually
released it slightly before
and we knew that we had defined
enough thin slice of value.
So our product research came in
and said, we've defined
a thin enough slice
that it's useful.
And so we combined all those
things about why we were trying
to do it and we had a good enough story
and we had all the go to market material.
And combining all those
things then allowed us to push
that button and have the
faith to take that step,
that will vary from
organization to organization
is what I'll say on that.
But as long as you're firm on your why
and you've identified
that first thin slice
and you've secured it to, you know,
you've got your sign-offs,
just push the button,
take the step.
- Yeah, I think just
to add to that as well,
this is just the start.
You know, we've got the compliance
and we want to go at pace
and we feel we've done that.
What we can do now is we can start
to work with our customers.
So we've worked with our
partners, AWS and Dynatrace.
We can now start to
work with our customers
and find out where their value is.
You know, we've opened
their eyes to what AI can do
with our products.
It's now let's go together,
let's go at pace together.
Let's help you with your challenges,
let's help you figure out
where we can help you.
You know, our systems
are highly configurable,
so how they can be used varies
from customer to customer,
but you know, focusing on
kind of customer success,
our products, our ecosystem,
work with them and see what, what's next.
So who knows what it could be?
Are they ready for,
you know, those changes
to a policy that impact the premium?
Or are they wanting to go,
actually let's work more on
the policy lifecycle changes
which are left risky.
- Okay, so we don't have a massive amount
of time left, unfortunately.
- That's fine.
- Sorry, talked a bit.
You like to talk.
So I guess very quickly,
rather than own full Q&A
obviously Chris,
just then you were talking
about your customers
and their success.
Have you got any insights around
how this has specifically impacted them?
- The biggest one is,
is fear at the moment, it's something new.
So we've been on this
journey for 12 months
and you know, we've been engaging
them and talking to them.
So it's bringing them on the journey now
is probably the biggest
thing I've got to say.
What we don't want to do is
kind of scare them with
the new technology.
Is that me?
So that would kind of be my thing.
That's the biggest
learning I've got so far.
But I think internally as
well, we've learned a lot.
I think the opportunities
that Kiro, Dynatrace, MCP
and all the other MPCs are
going to give us is really going
to open up internal opportunities.
You know, we speak about a
lot about AI and efficiencies,
but it's trying to find
the why but also the what.
And I think Dynatrace MCPs really going
to open up opportunities
at our service desk level
from a first line and
also second line as well.
- I guess, Matt,
have you got any key takeaways you'd like
to give from this whole experience?
- Know your why, right.
So with AI it's not about
how many things you can do, right.
Because it can do so many things.
It's about picking the right
thing that works for you,
make sure it's part of your
core value proposition.
And I know that probably
sounds really basic,
but that is so key to
actually getting value.
What you're giving your
customers today without AI
is value enough, right.
Because obviously you're
still making the sales,
you guys are all still
sitting here getting paid.
To take that next step.
You gotta think, right,
what is AI gonna do
that's gonna transform that
and grab onto that and just
run with it as fast as you can?
- And it's finally very quickly as well.
Obviously as Ishan mentioned AgentCore,
obviously a very big thing
for AWS at the moment.
Obviously, didn't exist when
you were doing all of this,
but I guess the question is
have you started utilizing that?
How do you think it's
gonna impact your estate
and what you've built so far
and and what's your thoughts?
- Yes, we're actually working on V2
of that engine room already.
So again, if Matt's still
here, he's in the back there.
He's working on V2 for me.
But essentially yes it
will very much include
AgentCore as an option.
We see it as a way to remember
I always said we needed
to wash, rinse, repeat those thin slices.
We see AgentCore is giving
us that repeatable capability
of doing that and it'll probably allow us
to embrace MCP in our backend
to start to to connect
to these because we've got
all these API interfaces.
So it's like right, we need to MCPify,
if that's a word, all those things
and we think AgentCore
is gonna help with that.
We also know that as our
customers catch up so to speak
and they come up with
their own chat things
or LLM things
, they're gonna want to use
us as a tool in MCP speak.
So we are probably gonna need
to offer them an MCP interface
again, which we think we can do with this.
And it's especially helpful
'cause I think it was just
this week that API gateway
now supports that type of transaction.
So again, you're looking
at our model going,
you can see the V2 before I
even really need to draw it.
- Anything you wanted to add to Ishan?
Anything that could help 'em further?
- Yeah, so I think really what
from the capability point-of-view,
AgentCore does have
these composable services
that you can use in order
to build these agents
and go to production reliably.
But I think I also want
to focus on developing a success criteria
as we are all thinking about building AI
and especially like
measurable success criteria
because that's really how
you are going to measure
if your agent is performing or not
and usually the success criteria
should be very much related
to what your business metrics are.
So I want you to also like focus on that
and have the experience piece a part
of that success criteria.
- So if you do have any more questions we
will be outside for a little bit.
So do feel free and come ask questions
to any of us about anything.
Probably specifically Dynatrace, CDL
and what they've done on their journey.
But obviously Dynatrace,
we do have have a booth in the expo.
So please do come and see us at 575.
And if you did want some something to read
on your potentially long
back, long walk back
to one of the other
hotels for your next talk,
feel free to scan on the QR
codes as well, thank you.
- [Matthew] Thank you Everybody.
- Thanks so much.
- Appreciate your time.
(audience clapping)